INTERVENTION FOR THE GOOD OF
THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST MARK STEYN IS A
PRAYING MAN.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT TO
ASSESS WHAT WE HAVE JUST
LEARNED FROM NANCY PELOSI
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT TO
MAKE OF THAT THAT WAS A
PRESS CONFERENCE WE SHOULD
NOTE FOR OUR VIEWERS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> I THINK, ACTUALLY, IN A
SENSE, SHE DOES BELIEVE IN
DIVINE INTERVENTION.
THEY WERE LET DOWN BY BOB
MUELLER WHO WAS THE NEAREST
THING TO JESUS TO WALK ON
THE FACE OF THIS EARTH FOR
THE DEMOCRATS UNTIL HE
ACTUALLY ISSUED HIS REPORT.
THEY HAVE BEEN LET DOWN BY
JUDGES AND NOW THEY ARE
PUTTING THEIR FAITH IN THE
BIG GUY HIMSELF.
AND WHEN SHE SAYS SHE WANTS
AN INTERVENTION, BASICALLY
SHE WANTS GOD TO SEND MOSES
BACK DOWN WITH A BRAND NEW
TABLET ON WHICH THE 25TH
AMENDMENT OF THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION IS INSCRIBED
AND THAT MOSES WILL THEN
PERSUADE EVERYBODY ELSE THAT
IT'S TIME FOR TRUMP TO BE
DEPOSED FROM OFFICE.
AND IT'S -- AND IT'S A
STRANGE WELL BECAUSE THE
OSTENTATIOUS RELIGIOUS CITY
OF MRS. PELOSI IS AT ODDS
WITH THE SHEAR INSANITY OF
WHAT HER PARTY IS PROPOSING.
THE PARTY HAS ACTUALLY
CHANGED A LOT, TUCKER, IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF ELECTION
CYCLES.
YOU KNOW THE WAY IT USED TO
BE PEOPLE LIKE JOHN KERRY
WOULD TWIST THEMSELVES LIKE
A PRETZEL TO SAY HOW
PERSONALLY PASSIONATELY
OPPOSED TO ABORTION THEY
WERE BUT THAT THEY WOULD
NEVER LET THEIR DEEPLY HELD
PERSONAL CATHOLIC FAITH
INTERFERE WITH THEIR
LEGISLATIVE AGENDA.
THERE IS NO PRETENSE OF THAT
NOW.
SHE LEADS A PARTY THAT'S IN
FAVOR OF FOURTH TRIMESTER
ABORTION.
PREGNANT MEN.
MS-13 ON EVERY CORNER.
A SANCTUARY NATION WITH
LAWYERS FOR ANY 6 BILLION
PEOPLE AROUND THE PLANET WHO
WANT TO COME HERE AND CLAIM
THE RIGHT TO LIVE HERE.
AND I THINK SHE IS DOING
THIS IN A SENSE TO PORTRAY
TRUMP AS THE CRAZY ONE
WHEREAS IT'S THEIR AGENDA
THAT IS CRAZY.
>> Tucker: BUT WHY GO
THROUGH THE MOTIONS.
IT'S AGGRESSIVELY SECULAR
PARTY AND AGGRESSIVELY
ANTI-CHRISTIAN PARTY
OBVIOUSLY AS YOU SAID IT
WASN'T ALWAYS.
FAR FROM IT.
THERE WERE A LOT OF SINCERE
CHRISTIANS.
JIMMY CARTER IS A SINCERE
CHRISTIAN NEW
CHRISTIAN AEW
CHRISTIAN AMONG OTHERS.
IT'S NOW ANTI-CHRISTIAN AND
LET'S NOT LIE ABOUT IT.
WHY EVEN BOTHER TO GIVE US
THE GOD TALK?
>> I THINK THE GOD TALK IS
INTERESTING.
BECAUSE, AS I SAY, SO MUCH
OF THIS STUFF, LIKE THE AN
ABOLITION OF THE SEXES AND
INFANTICIDE IS SO OFF THE
CHARTS I THINK THEY ACTUALLY
WANT TO CREATE A KIND OF NEW
RELIGION FOR SECULARISTS.